okay welcome back everybody
gonna try to get this computer screen to
display on the board okay so today we're
going to talk a little bit about
numerical solutions to P DS and we're
going to go beyond the linear types of
hedis that we've been solving in the
class so far this is a huge field there
are literally dozens of classes you
could take on the solution like the
subject of numerical solutions to
physical problems and I'm going to give
you just the most kind of high-level
overview and just show you a few things
I am by no means an expert in the
numerical solution of PDE s but I want
to give you kind of a flavor for how
things would go and then all of next
week we're going to be talking about
data methods so at the end of today's
lecture I hope to motivate that
numerically solving PDEs will generate
tremendous amounts of data and all of
next week we're going to be talking
about how do you handle large data sets
that you might get from numerix or
experiments or things like that okay I
don't have a ton prepared today so I was
hoping that this would be somewhat
freeform so if you have any questions or
want to talk about anything please feel
free to interrupt at any point
yeah I should be posting your final
sometime either today or tomorrow
so it'll be over over the weekend
probably why yes on the podium stands
okay sure
okay
okay great I'll just work on the board
until then Thanks okay so I'll just tell
you the kinds of problems we're gonna
solve in a computer and give you just a
little bit of a summary so we've already
seen a little bit of how to solve this
before let's think there's a few
different things we've done
so what numerical solutions to pd's have
we seen before we've done a couple yeah
okay the 2d heat equation and 2d
Laplace's equation and what is the
difference between Laplace's equation
and the heat equation so DDT equals zero
so it's the steady state distribution
after a really long amount of time okay
and we actually solved that two
different ways so how did we solve the
heat equation and the Laplace equation
in the computer
just write it down we have a UT that
looks good equals u X X awesome thank
you okay so we have our PDE
how do we solve this before so we first
we use finite difference we just cooked
up a big rectangular grid and we
approximated the derivative at each of
the grid points by looking at the
stencil surrounding it with its
neighbors and we did finite difference
in x and y and you can approximate
second derivatives and things like that
how else do we do it well we all we
actually solved it using variation of
parameters analytically we found the
eigenvalues of this problem and plotted
the modes one by one we just added up
all of the signs to approximate the
solution I think when we did the heat
equation we had a 1d heat equation where
I took a step function and we had this
as the initial condition to a heat
equation which was just UT equals alpha
u xx and we solved this one using the
FFT okay so these are the two kind of
basic big categories of ways that you
can solve partial differential equations
you can solve them using a grid of
spacial points and finite differences or
you can transform them into the
frequency domain and use what are called
spectral methods so if you're in the
frequency domain your methods are
spectral and you have nice properties
like your derivatives are essentially
just algebraic so your Fourier transform
of DF DX is just I Omega F hat that's
super nice you just multiply it by a
vector and the nice thing is that you
can use these spectral methods and these
finite difference methods to solve
nonlinear problems they don't have to be
your PD doesn't have to
linear' for you to take and find a
solution I could have you T equals minus
u times u X plus u xx okay so this is a
nonlinear differential equation why is
it nonlinear right because I have a
product of two terms just not linear in
in the solution U and so this is
actually a famous equation called the
burgers equation I forget where the
apostrophe goes I don't think if the
burgers is equation its burgers equation
and essentially this is like a baby
version of the 2d of the Navy or Stokes
equations ok this is like a baby fluids
equation and it has a lot of interesting
characteristics that we might actually
want to solve in real life okay so let's
think about how to understand this so
this is a 1d equation U is just a very
function of space and time okay so this
is kind of a 1d model for a fluid and in
particular it's a 1d model for a fluid
with shockwaves so compressible gas
dynamics
with a shockwave very very important if
you want to understand detonation waves
compression waves if you want to
understand flow over a Boeing wing or a
fighter jet wing this is kind of a
starting point to think about analyzing
this problem okay so what we have is our
solution U in time the partial
derivative with respect to time is equal
to the sum of these two terms
okay so u xx whenever you see u t equals
u xx what equation do you think of sorry
heat equation and what is the solution
of the heat equation characterized by
exponential the do what
so I'd like to think of this in terms of
buzzwords my heat equation diffuses my
solution if you like you could say that
it takes my initial conditions and
convulsed them with a Gaussian where
that Gaussian variance is increasing
with time so it's just spreading them
out more and more over time so this is a
diffusion operator
it diffuses my solution and you times UX
is called my convection operator it's
going to take information into you and
it's going to carry it along like
travelling waves okay so this is called
convection so maybe before I solve this
really hard problem in a computer I'll
just show you how to solve a much
simpler problem so let's say that I had
u T equals u X some C times u X okay
this one's linear right so we can solve
this using lots and lots of different
techniques so this is a linear wave
equation and what you can find out is if
you write down the solution you would
essentially say that U of X minus CT is
equal to U at time T equals 0 so
whatever my initial condition was is
just going to be carried along in time
moving along in space so let's say I
have some initial condition like that
this is X and this is U then what
happens is in time this PDE just carries
this wave to the right at a constant
speed C yep so at time at time T you
have the exact same pattern but it's
moved over at speed C so C times T over
X
so this is the probably the simplest
partial differential equation the
solutions are really simple nothing
diffuses nothing spreads out you doesn't
change at all all that happens to you is
that it just gets shifted in space it
moves over at a constant wave speed seat
and you can verify that if you take the
partials of this with respect to T and
then the partial of this with respect to
X it'll satisfy this equation so this
really is exactly the solution to that
partial differential equation and what
we find is that the wave speed the speed
at which this wave of information
propagates is just given by C the
constant linear coefficient and my PDE
so this is kind of a constant wave speed
problem what I could also do is I could
have this nonlinear term which is
instead of a constant wave speed C I'm
gonna have my wave speed be u times u X
so this is called a variable wave speed
because instead of a constant rate in
which my wave is propagating now the
wave propagates proportional to how big
the wave is the bigger the wave this
part propagates faster than this part
because U as bigger here than here okay
so this nonlinear problem is actually
somewhat easy to physically intuitively
understand is in the linear constant
wave speed case every piece of this wave
propagates at the same speed regardless
of amplitude but in this case if I have
this wave the parts with a larger
amplitude you are actually moving faster
this one's moving faster than this one
and that's moving faster than this one
and this one's barely moving at all okay
and so some very interesting things
happen in this equation this is called
the
the inviscid burgers equation doesn't
sound like a very tasty burger or would
not eat an inviscid burger envisage just
means that there's no viscosity there's
no diffusion there's no UX X term okay
so no UX X diffusion now what do you
imagine what happened I let's say I take
this this solution and I want to move it
over to the right at a constant wave
speed see we can picture what's going to
happen this entire shape remains
unchanged and it's just moving from left
to right what's going to start happening
if I allow my larger amplitude pieces to
move to the right faster
right so this piece is going to start to
overcome the pieces below it and they're
going to start to stack up and become
steeper and steeper and steeper and
eventually what I'm going to get is
something that looks more like like that
I'm going to have the faster parts
crashing on top of the slower parts and
stacking up into these very very very
sharp wavefronts super sharp wave fronts
these are shockwaves that's exactly what
shockwaves are if you look at the Navy
or stokes equations for like a
compressible fluid a gas what you find
is that shockwaves are faster fluid
stacking up on top of slower fluid
creating these very very thin very very
high shear high gradient regions and
then those travel as fast as they
possibly can and the the speed at which
they travel is given by how tall how big
you is in this case okay now so what we
have is a solution the convection term
this nonlinear burgers equation term is
taking my original solution and in time
it's causing my solution to create these
shockwaves and what the diffusion term
does is whenever you have a really so in
these regions where I have a very very
tall stacked wave what can you say about
the derivative and X
what is the derivative of U with respect
to X near these shockwaves
it's nearly infinite huge right these
things are just like a ton of change in
a tiny DX so it's nearly infinite DDX
and so what that means is that this
diffusion term is going to be very very
large and I'm going to have a huge
diffusion force trying to spread this
out what if this was what if I took this
solution I plugged it into my heat
equation very very quickly these sharp
shockwaves would kind of level out they
they'd spread out they diffuse because
that's what this diffusion operator does
so in this viscid viscous burgers
equation because I have diffusion so if
I have a UX X term then that gives me a
finite width for each of these the
diffusion is constantly counteracting
this shock wave stacking force and so
eventually I have some sharp but finite
width this has a finite width shock wave
and so the shock width is determined by
the diffusion balancing out the stacking
force of this convection term okay so
I'm telling you a lot about this problem
first of all because it's really
interesting it's one of the only
non-linear problems we can actually kind
of understand just by making physical
arguments and it's very important for
fluids and materials and all kinds of
systems this is just a 1d model problem
that has a lot of the features that we
want for a real systems like shockwaves
but we're also getting into this
numerical issue that if I just had the
convection term then these shock waves
would become infinitely steep and
infinitely thin and eventually I
wouldn't be able to compute use of X
because it would be infinite okay so I'm
guessing that if I tried to just saw
the inviscid burgers equation any
numerical scheme that I cook up is going
to blow up to infinity it's gonna just
crash my code and so I have to have this
diffusion term to numerically solve this
I have to be spreading out these things
that are trying to become infinite
gradients using some numerical diffusion
okay so these are the two examples that
I'm going to show you in MATLAB code I
don't really you know I don't expect you
to know how to analyze nonlinear PDEs
that's not what I'm trying to get out
but I just want to write down an
important nonlinear PDE that has some
interesting physical properties and I'm
going to show you that we can in fact
analyze it in the computer okay any
questions about this burgers equation
before we go to the computer
okay there's probably a sign missing
here this is probably plus C of x equals
u so that look better that looks better
would you like me to show you why this
actually solves the equation or does
everyone feel okay about this who wants
me to show it yeah okay I just realized
this is probably the simplest PDE and if
I don't show you why this is true that
would be an oversight so I can compute
the partial derivative of U with respect
to either of these two variables so
let's say that this is the solution so U
of X and T equals let's be a lot more
precise here
okay
okay so what's the partial of this with
respect to T all right so I got a minus
C a minus C term and this is in the
exposition so a minus C u X partial of
this is just there's a constant of 1 C
UX and those really do cancel out to 0
so essentially having this this position
here means that when I take the partial
with respect to T it really does balance
the C times the partial with respect to
X but what this means is that if I had I
think I was really in precise so if I
have some solution this is U of X at
time 0 my initial condition then my U of
X at time T so U of X at time T is going
to be my initial condition solution my
initial time 0 solution which shifted
over in space by C T so I take this and
I shift it over in space so by C T and
so now it's the exact same solution as
my initial condition but I've just
shifted it over by C T in space ok all
right I should code this up
all right I'm going to start with the
wave equation the constant velocity wave
equation right so that one should be
easy that's the one that just moves over
in time then we're going to add a
variable wave speed that's non linear
term and then we're gonna add the
diffusion term alright let's see if I
have this somewhere
okay so I'm going to make a small D X
and I'm going to have l equals 20 and
I'm gonna have an X from minus L over 2
and increments of DX to L over 2 minus
DX I'm gonna start with F equals 0 times
X and then I'm gonna say f equals a set
this is a hyperbolic secant function of
X and I'm going to plot X by F and save
this as test wave okay so this is my
initial my initial condition for you
just a set function it looks like a such
as just a Gaussian okay so it's a
Gaussian function and now what I'm going
to do is we're going to solve the
equation u sub t equals C U sub X but
I'm going to do this by taking the FFT
to get my derivative okay so I'm going
to integrate in time in increments of
0.025 for K equals 1 to 100 so I'm going
to take 100 time steps time is equal to
K times DT and I'm going to integrate
this PDE using OD e45 so this is the
cool part is that once I take and I use
the fast Fourier transform with respect
to X this right hand side just becomes a
constant you know K times u hat so my
partial differential equation becomes an
ordinary differential equation and I can
solve that ordinary differential
equation using OD e45 so I'm going to
say T by y equals ode45 at t by y and i
need a right-hand side remember OD 45
needs the right-hand side y dot equals
F of Y I need and I'll define this
right-hand side in a minute
I need a timespan I'm gonna integrate
from 0 to DT and I need an initial
condition which in this case is f my set
function okay so let's make our right
hand side function I'll call this right
hand side right hand side okay so my
right hand side for my OD e looks like
what what is my right hand side need to
be for OD 45
okay so in OD 45 here maybe we should be
more explicit so we have UT equals C
times UX and so we're gonna FFT we're
going to take the Fourier transform with
respect to X because we have an infinite
spatial domain okay and we're gonna get
u hat D DT equals I Omega so I times my
C times Omega u hat this is just an Eau
de right this is just an OEE in U hat
these are numbers okay so it's no longer
a PDE now we have an Eau de and this is
my right hand side my right hand side is
I times C times Omega times you have
okay so I need the DF out is a function
of RHS T comma F comma L L is the length
of my domain T as time f is my f is you
let's call this u okay and then we're
gonna say the number of points in my
function is the length of U u hat is the
FFT of you my Kappa the wave number here
in discrete Fourier transform we just
call this Kappa is two times pi divided
by L times minus and x over 2 to n X
over 2 minus 1 and then Kappa equals FFT
shift of Kappa remember this is exactly
what we did before when we looked at the
spectral derivative we you know when I
do FFT in MATLAB it orders my wave
numbers Kappa in a funny order and so I
have to use FFT shift to get them back
to the MATLAB standard order
okay and then D you hat equals I times
Kappa times u hat that's my derivative
in the Fourier domain super simple I
just multiply two vectors Kappa and u
hat okay and then finally I say D u
equals IFFT do u hat and do you out
equals -2 you I probably was trying to
solve this equation so that u sub T
equals minus C u X and so that there's a
minus IC Omega you have
okay are there questions about how I'm
making this right hand side in MATLAB
with the FFT does the basic idea make
sense or should I go through kind of the
high-level overview of the steps again
yeah yes so FFT shift so my frequencies
with the discrete Fourier transform are
like e to the I to PI over L times K
where K can go from minus n over 2 to n
over Q ok so that's this minus n over 2
to n over 2 times my basic unit of
frequency which is 2 PI over L and then
what so that goes from negative numbers
to positive numbers through 0 and FFT
shift takes that and just literally
shifts it over and copies the second
half to the first and it's it's weird it
just takes this the sequence 4 minus n
over 2 through 0 to n over 2 and I
believe it chops this part off and puts
it on the right-hand side so it takes
the first half and puts it onto the
second half that's weird it does that
because it's faster to compute the FF to
you that way
okay so what I'm doing is I'm
integrating I'm actually inverse for you
transforming both of these sides so I'm
really just looking at D DT of U equals
the inverse Fourier transform of this
and then I'm going to plot what I have
okay so for each of these little DTS I'm
assuming that ode45 might take a lot of
little steps and I just want the last
step so f is going to be the last the
last column of Y the last time step it
took I'm going to plot X by the real
part of F axis - 10 - 10 - 1.5 to 1.5
and I'm going to pause a little bit so
this might work
okay for K equals 1 to 100
okay my code crashed
okay it didn't like that
i multiplied kappa by u hat it said the
matrix dimensions didn't agree what
could be some possible explanations for
why those wouldn't agree right Kappa is
a vector of frequencies you have as my
FFT vector why might they not have the
same size well it could be different
lengths but in this case it's because
one of them is a column vector and the
other one's a row vector and that lab is
not gonna figure that out for me so what
I need to do here is just put a
transpose on my Kappa I just need to
turn it into a column vector okay so
this is my such function solution to my
PDE
it's just moving from left to right at a
constant velocity one so I hope it's
been two point five seconds my wave
speed was one so how far do you think
the peak should be from zero now to
point five and we can check that I
really I haven't checked this yet so I'm
hoping it is actually two point five and
it is okay so this is actually solving
the problem we have this basic shape and
it's just translating from left to right
at a wave speed of one okay so this
basic strategy is really simple I turn
my PDE into an OD e by evaluating the
right-hand side and the frequency domain
i compute this derivative in the
frequency domain I get this nice
algebraic expression easy to compute I
inverse fast Fourier transform and I get
UT equals some vector of numbers so this
is like an OD E and every component of U
what is my size of my size of F is 2,000
by one so this is 2,000 OD es that I'm
solving all simultaneously with OD 45
this is like a huge vector of OD is a
huge system of
Odie's you know you dot equals eight
times you okay any questions about how
we cooked up this right hand side or
turn this into an OD e or the FFT or the
inverse FFT
yeah
okay so there is a lot of data that
comes out of this so let's say my data
equals zeroes and it's going to be the
length of F by 100 so what I'm gonna do
is for every solution for every time
step I have a vector u my solution and
I'm gonna have a hundred of those
vectors as this thing evolves over time
and I'm gonna stack each of those into
the column of data okay so every column
of data is going to be a solution of my
PDE at a different snapshot in time so
here I'm gonna say data : comma K equals
the real part of F okay so this is just
running through super fast because I
didn't pause and now if I look at the
size of data I've got a huge matrix of
data which has my PDE solution for all
hundred snapshots in time I can do
things like look at image SC of data I
can just plot my data and I can see my
such my my such wave moving in time so
the x axis is time and you can see that
my sech is just moving to the right in
time the right is dis directly okay if I
wanted to I could plot the surf of this
let's see where is that
so I'm just gonna plot this surf of my
data plotted as a surface and you can
see my solution here so as time
increases from zero to a hundred my such
solution is moving to the right in space
okay and this kind of plot can be really
really useful for more sophisticated
partial differential equations if
there's actually more stuff happening
you would want to see it in both space
and in time so this is the XT diagram
that we drew at the very last part of
last lecture okay so now what I want to
do is we have a wave equation so now
what I'm going to do is add a nonlinear
wave speed and a diffusion term okay
where do I add a nonlinear wave speed
and a diffusion term in this procedure
how do I do that
how do I do the exact same thing here to
this equation
right so all the changes is this right
hand side okay
so right hand side new okay so I have my
derivative of U hat I so I also need my
second derivative of U hat D D U hat so
D D u hat equals I squared times Kappa
squared times u so that's minus Kappa
squared dot times u hat okay I squared
Kappa squared you have and okay so I
have D u DD u equals IFFT of D D u hat
and D F out is this combination of - u -
u dot times D u Plus D D u so I just
went through and I computed all the
things I care about
i computed ux x ux u i did these
derivatives in the frequency domain IFFT
them to get the derivatives but then I
inverse FFT them because I'm actually
want to solve this in the real spatial
domain so my right hand side is u dot
times D u plus D D u this is super
simple right I just need I just need to
take a couple of FFTs and a couple of
inverse F F T's and I have all my
derivatives I don't need to do a finite
difference if I wanted to I could have
this code do a really really big finite
difference to calculate D U and V U but
it would be less accurate and a lot more
code and slower
okay so now this test wave is really
test burgers equation okay let's see if
this works
should I pause for too much time okay
and I also only want a tiny amount of
diffusion 0.01
I want a little itty-bitty amount of
diffusion I can have some constants 0.01
diffusion okay so this is my solution my
such equation as we're evolving in time
for this burgers equation and notice
what's happening as we evolved the
solution forward in time the tallest
part of my function the the part with
the biggest magnitude of U is travelling
the fastest and it's overwhelming the
slower parts of you that are to the
right of it until it creates this large
steep shockwave and the only reason that
this shockwave doesn't become infinitely
thin and sharp is because we have this
diffusion term that's constantly
spreading it out so what do you think is
going to happen when I remove the
diffusion term when I just completely
get rid of diffusion
well it'll get even sharper and then my
Codel blah I think that's what I expect
will happen and let's integrate for just
a little bit longer to see if that
actually happens so to remove diffusion
entirely I just multiplied that term by
zero easy and now when I run this it's
probably gonna kill my computer okay
it's gonna get steeper and steeper and
steeper and nothing's gonna stop it
oh no so now the derivative became
infinite
okay and now I better stop this before
my computer dies okay so you really do
need this little bit of numerical
diffusion in some problems or else
things are gonna blow up they're gonna
become unbounded the derivatives are
gonna become unbounded this term here
becomes infinite that's why you get a
bunch of high frequency stuff because
all of the modes are getting amplified
by that one discontinuity but adding a
little teeny amount of diffusion allows
you to have a finite shock wave that
actually propagates nicely in your PDE
okay so you can definitely do this in 2d
and 3d the basic idea is that I can
solve PDE s
using OD e45 as long as I take my state
and I consider it as a really really
tall discretized vector of U at X 1 U at
X 2 U at X 3 and so forth and evaluating
the right hand side is a little
difficult because I have to compute
things like D u DX and D D u DX and
things like that and so here I opt to do
it using the fast Fourier transform
because it's more accurate and it's
faster but I could have done this using
finite difference that would have been
totally fine ok any questions about this
this general general picture
so I'm only providing you with an
extremely brief sketch of a very very
very important topic if you think you
might be doing numerical simulations of
physical systems there are lots of
interesting courses and applied math in
mechanical and aerospace engineering
there's a great book spectral methods in
MATLAB which is a really really really
good starting point it's something like
a hundred and fifty pages you could read
this on you know a long bus ride a
really long bus ride and you can really
start to see how these things would look
for more complicated problems like 2d
problems I'll just show you a nice
example that I found in this book this
is one of my favorites let's do a close
all clear all so this is a pretty slick
example of a 2d wave equation so you
just have imagine that this is just a
tight rubber surface stretched over a
square drum and you start it with an
initial Gaussian and you let it go this
thing's gonna like shake around and
oscillate and it's a super simple code
it's only this is from spectral methods
in MATLAB just slightly modified it's
forty lines of code with comments and
all it's based on is the FFTs in two
dimensions okay so here we have
something like UT T equals C squared
times u X x plus u YY so how do i
compute these derivatives u xx and u iy
I just do them separately so I still
take U hat I'm still looking at you hat
but now I have I squared k1 squared u
hats plus I squared k2 squared u hats
where k1 is the X wave number and k2 is
the Y wave number okay so now I have two
different frequencies I have the
frequencies of sine waves and X and I
have the frequencies of sine waves in Y
and I have two different vectors Kappa
you know Capital One and Kappa
and it's the exact same thing I I time
step this equation using those Kappas
I'm just gonna run this one more time
because I like watching it very nice
super simple incredibly fast and
accurate is there another one this one's
kind of cool so this is a two soliton
example where you have essentially two
such functions that are travelling waves
and they're gonna pass through each
other and then essentially retain their
shape on either side my scales are kind
of crappy but they're super posing
there's some interference some nonlinear
interference this is a nonlinear PDE
called the core trig DeVry equation and
then the solitons pass through each
other and go about their merry way so
what are some examples of solitons in
the real world solitary waves that
retain their shape even as they pass
through a nonlinear system
it's a little parcel of light and a
fiber-optic cable is a salat on shorting
yours equation is extremely non-linear
but little gaussian such packets of
light passing through a wire are
solitary waves that retain their shape
even as they propagate through this
nonlinear PDE and they can pass through
each other I can have two waves at
different wave speeds pass right through
each other in time they have some
nonlinear interference but then on the
other side they retain their shape
another example of solitons
in fact solitons were discovered in an
english channel on the side of a river
so they had these channels and they
noticed that there is some some person
on a horse notice that there was a large
disturbance on one end of the channel it
created a large wave and that wave
traveled through the channel at a
constant wave speed with exactly the
same shape for about a mile and he rode
and followed this wave for a mile and
then he went home and wrote down some
equations and discovered that there is a
soliton
that is a shape that can pass through a
nonlinear equation as if it were linear
so there are certain special shapes that
can pass through nonlinear equations as
if they were linear they're called
solitons these are just some examples of
how to compute them I could probably
find an example of a salat on
and guy wireless
okay maybe my Wireless is dead okay so
the big picture is that you can solve
complicated nonlinear PDEs in a computer
using the fast Fourier transform or
finite difference most of the time we
prefer fast Fourier transform because
it's faster more accurate easy to
implement so what the last thing I want
to get at today is this idea that the
solutions of these PDEs might be
extraordinarily large so we looked at
simple solutions to a 1d burgers
equation for a hundred time steps and we
ended up having two hundred thousand
numbers and a matrix okay so imagine
that I want to simulate a volcano
erupting okay so I have a volcano
erupting and we know that in space and
time there's orders of magnitude of
scale of sizes okay so the largest
structure of the plume is going to be on
the same order of magnitude as the
entire volcano but if you zoom into a
tiny little piece of this there's gonna
be some interesting roiling turbulence
and the micro scales might be on the
order of millimeters or micrometers for
a volcano okay so you have relevant
structures on the order of millimeters
that you might want to resolve all the
way up to thousands of meters and this
isn't a one-dimensional equation this is
a three-dimensional equation so very
very quickly the data associated with
the solution to your PDE might be in the
terabytes or more okay so you might have
gigabytes or terabytes of data for one
solution of one partial differential
equation and so what we're gonna talk
about next week are essentially data
methods to handle systems where you have
tons and tons of data okay so I want to
find the patterns that matter in this
data so that I don't have to keep track
of terabytes of data and so that I can
plot and understand this thing more
reasonably so all of next week we're
going to talk about data we're going to
talk about the singular value
decomposition
and how to visualize and understand data
it's probably my favorite part of the
class so we'll start on Monday thank you